[Music]
you're giving advice right now and like
some people on the other side right now
are going to do the scary version of it
i'm in jail
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk a new
interview session
right now with josh york i'm gonna let
me say this simple there's a single
single reason this episode is happening
and it's called perseverance i
am a big fan excuse me of telling a lot
of you right now to dm
100 like every day all i hear is
complaining i read it all day long my
life
is garbage these days all i do is read
complaining and
there's so much solutions in an internet
world
that it just makes me like i'm so
passionate if you're listening right now
for people to know how in control you
actually are
with the internet because the internet
doesn't know what school you went to
where you came from what your family's
last name is it's just a platform
and so when i say my hyperbole of like
hey
you know like just dm 100 people that
you want to work for or like
make like just make content for somebody
and show them like just take it
like i mean it like 4 000 will say no
but 4001 says yes and isn't that better
than the [ __ ] job you have like
like everyone's like i want to live my
dream i'm like wouldn't you like if i
told you you would 100 have your dream
come true
if you actually dm'd on instagram four
thousand and one people
i would argue almost everybody would do
that logically
it's just that you don't believe me when
i say it and so the reason i really
wanted josh on the show is like
he just basically outwilled me to be on
this show
like just like and then when i sat down
with him i did some speech in like the
upper
east or west side and then we had a
coffee or a lunch
and like basically that's all he's ever
really done and very honestly like
he's here for his selfish wants and
needs of exposure which is right
all humans are right in a good way i'm
here selfishly because
i think me setting up this podcast and
telling you how we even got on it
now what's gonna happen next is 8 000 of
you are going to bug the [ __ ] out of me
and i'll tell you right now 7
99 of you will never be here you know it
took
you know serendipity moments in time
and the fact that he's actually built
something which is an important part of
this story
but for there to be no confusion there's
one selfish reason he's on this show
which is
every one of you can have the business
the job the show you want to be on
if you actually understand how to ask i
do think that there's a fine line
between
annoyance i mean there's so many people
bugging the living [ __ ] out of me right
actively right now there are thousands
of people bothering me
with the way they're emailing me my
favorite is when you email me 97 times
in a row thinking that's gonna
what happens is we my admins delete it
and then the i.t department blocks
your email and anything to associate
with you in perpetuity
so like there's the right way to jab
there's the right way to have per listen
the
perfect balance of persistence
and charm is very difficult it is a
natural innate thing
but here's what i will say if you try to
figure out how to bring value to
somebody
and you persevere like i really do think
there's a play here and honestly
to be very frank i think josh building
really meaningful business
i'm not in a mindset of investing now
i'd rather buy sports cards than invest
in companies
but um even though it wasn't like
a perfect execution for me of like i'm
getting this value then let me have him
on the podcast
it was it was so important for me to
have an
actual human manifestation of the thing
that i want all of you to do out there
which is like look
if you want to be a rapper produ a
producer
for rap like go ask 47
000 times metro boomin you know sunny
digital
like murder be like just [ __ ] ask
like [ __ ] ask
now if you know how to ask with grace
it's gonna work better
if you know how to reverse engineer the
person of what they care about at this
moment
like if somebody has a new album coming
out and they're your favorite rapper
uh young nudie has an album out today
if not if nudie's your guy like you
could have made 25 pieces of content
on your if you're that person and sent
it dm to him
to help him post on his social channels
because everybody needs more content
and then that might have been the reason
you got the job so there's a cadence to
it there's one
huge setup cause i'm gonna let josh talk
most of the rest away
of why he's here and uh and that's it
that's [ __ ] it what's up bro
much listen first off i want to say is
that the value is definitely coming your
way
okay good and i'm telling you right now
not to be ballsy but this is going to go
down as the greatest podcast
you've ever done the content is going to
be pouring through this microphone i'm
telling you that right now
because my story is incredible i've done
a bootstrap as i like to refer to as
shoe dog in it
i've done it bootstrapped today we are
the fastest growing in the fitness space
we're disrupting the entire fitness
industry
and in 15 20 years just like i know
you're going to own the jets and i know
why you're going to own it
because you already own it in your head
i'm the same guy as you i know exactly
how you try to
help everybody who hears that why do so
many people
have it in their head and it doesn't
happen what's the disconnect between
having it in your head
and it actually happening from your
perspective yeah well first of all
everyone wants the gold
but people just say you know what i'll
settle for the silver people don't
actually cross the finish line
people i heard why number one from your
perspective one man's point of view well
first of all you said something the
other day that i was just watching i
love people fold like cheap chairs
i i believe business is 80 mindset
80 mindset i always put myself in the
most uncomfortable situations
like just so everyone knows i'll tell
you why because putting yourself in
uncomfortable situations allows you to
get comfortable
this had this has been going on four
years but i never stop
and you're just talking about a story
and i'll share a really great story so
when i first started my company
it's jim guys with the z but i needed
the s why because no one knew the brand
yet
and i knew people are going to go to the
s rather than the z
jim guys the s at the end of guys it's
with a z now i know it is yes but i
needed
the s because in the beginning of
starting most people won't think like
this
people are going to come to that site
and i'm going to lose business of course
so this guy al
shout out to my man alex he's in
colorado he was selling the website for
48 thousand dollars
i was lucky if i had 48 cents in my
pocket so what i did was i literally
googled looked up the domain
went on his site you know and i called
him once hang up hang up hang up hang
out we're like 50 times in now i was
like you know what
i got his address i'm gonna go to his
house i book a flight to colorado
i go to his house before we go anywhere
else josh how many times have you been
in jail
never good i love it so this you know
even though you're stalking you're
you're you're doing it in a tasteful way
that doesn't scare people because people
are scary
yeah but i'm not scary man no no but
you're giving advice right now and like
some people on the other side right now
are going to do the scary version of it
in jail so like it's important for you
to break down i mean
you agree with me right like per like
like people go to [ __ ] jail 100
and you you have a better tack than that
i think you need i think actually
for no shits you have to figure out some
of the subtleness in that
because some people are just like some
people will run through this glass door
instead of opening it and in
that is the punch line yeah yeah go
ahead so anyway so we're at the [ __ ]
guy's house went to his house
knocking his door no one's there oh my
god i'll come back later no one's there
i'm like gee i'm in a rural area
so just with like eyesight you see the
house down all the way down
like a mile away knock on the door
chances are do you know al
oh he's away with his family this week
i'm like you got to be kidding me
so i write a note leave it to his
neighbor go to his house leave a note
about two weeks later i get a call from
out he goes you know this is actually
crazy now
that you're stalking me i said allison
i'm not stalking you can you not feel my
passion dripping through your phone
i said i'm gonna build the largest
fitness brand in the world
the chances of that not happening you
got a higher probability of seeing
elephants fly
on the 71st time he gave me the site for
free
mic drop right yeah at the end of the
day you got to just if you believe in
something just
some real [ __ ] because i think this i
think you know this is my podcast and
all i think about is the listeners and
how do i bring them value i'm pumped
that you're going to get this awareness
and people going to love you and all
that i mean that
i think you know me well enough at this
point i really do mean that i'm excited
for
that to be good for you i'm passionate
about them yes
so what there's so many people that i
can't wait to put restraining orders on
because they there's a lot of people
that do this wrong
i'm serious like let's really spend
something before we go to like we'll
find time for your part in this
straight up on some real [ __ ] what do
you think
allows you to go that hard
and get things done we're 99 i'm going
to say it again
99 of the people don't and end up in
really weird spaces
where they get in trouble they get
restraining orders they lose their way
they like what what do you think in your
attack like what like
you know where i'm going right because
there's a real bad version of you so
yeah and i know a lot of those people
i've had those people
i know unlimited people that have those
people and those people really lose
because it's not just getting
going to jail or restraining order you
get a reputation amongst winners and
then you're
blacklisted 100 how do you feel like
you've been able to
what's your gut tell you on that you may
not even know the answer no i do what
you do
i think every business in general
everyone's in the people business
i think the number one most important
thing is relationships and if you don't
have like i know you and i connected
right away even when we met
two years ago in vegas i knew we had a
connection yeah but i didn't go crazy
and keep calling you and calling you
because i knew that was the wrong play
you know originally i don't even know if
you know i sent tyler i shipped you a
tire
yes i remember that yeah and i wrote my
driving intentions all over your floor
and i know no one ever shipped you a
tire so i was like you know what i'll
start with something really out there no
i remember tyler came in he's like dude
did you meet some guy in vain i was like
yeah i met him in the side room good guy
ball dude this is literally what i said
he said you say handsome i didn't say
that i said ball dude i said uh
i remember this moment like it was
yesterday he's like he said the tire
like throw it away and went on my day
yeah
but that's an important part of the
story a hundred percent does that
actually happen
smart little move tyler comes in i'm
like [ __ ] that dude i don't want to
[ __ ]
throw it away i'm like i know what he's
doing because i know yeah i get it yeah
i'm like throw that [ __ ] now here's
real truth and this is why everybody has
to hear this because i'm obsessed
with this episode bringing value the
only reason
i told him to throw it away was when he
asked
this is not a joke i'm bi know this
anybody that you're desperate to meet is
busy and is a firefighter
100 right 100. so tyler asked me
a different moment where like a meeting
got cancelled and i weirdly had two
minutes
i would have like looked at it yep i
would have loved it he asked me
i don't remember this part inevitably
when a client fired us
when i had a problem with like an
employee right i was not in the right
mindset
to have that hundredth of a second that
is actually real life
real life uh i i facetimed somebody on
snapchat the other day for five minutes
they want a twitter thing with me
he said when he post when i posted him
in the 92nd club for like two seconds
uh this year he posted it or i posted it
and he said he had 800 friends reach out
to him like
just whatever the number was a lot
and and they're like oh my god you got
five minutes to for garyvee i've been f
i've watched every piece of content of
his for four years two years nine years
all these stories and he told me on the
facetime he goes i'm embarrassed because
i'd only discovered you 40 days earlier
and like and i was like man that's so
how life is right this guy discovered me
40 days earlier
and he gets this five minutes where
there's people who are listening right
now who've like been following me for
six years
have desperately looked for five minutes
and it hasn't happened because that's
that's real life that's not i'm a bad
guy
that's not your unlucky we have to we
have to wrap our head around serendipity
and look for the moments keep going let
me tell you something please
i'm a big believer and i know you're
down with this i think visualization
is a very big important component
success like i believe you have to
like i i i vision this like i've
actually seen this
and i've obsessed over just like again
we'll go back to the jets
i know for a fact that you're going to
own the jets because i know you're
obsessed with it
you have to be so obsessed but not to
the point where it's crazy scare the
[ __ ] out of people
will you scare people it's got to be
calculated have you ever killed anybody
no never man some people are funny the
other way some people are scared by me
and i'm like jesus i'm not oh you're a
nice guy man you're great
all right but so you know you have now
you have the s you have to yeah so i
have the s got the website it's great
you know and um
tell everybody the model because i think
the model is interesting because i think
it's a replicable model for some
hustlers listening
absolutely so it's a franchisee business
it's a franchise business right but
there's no physical locations
no location there's brick and mortar
it's a van we bring the work out to you
home office pool park place of warship
you want to work on the closet we want
to do a vayner media workout we
literally bring all the equipment
right to you i will give you lifetime
free sessions just because i'm going to
provide more value to you
i'll let my team work out your whole
crew in here for free for free that's on
record
that's number one number two we
literally bring the workout anywhere
okay we're disrupting the fitness
industry
right now we are literally the fastest
growing in the fitness space you think
of like
it makes sense right like if somebody
wants to buy these other gym franchises
i assume it's like a million dollars
investment how much is it for one
territory 80 thousand dollars
and how big is the territory it's a
hundred thousand people so you gotta get
in that territory you get ten thousand
approved households i see over a certain
medial income
i see and what is that level so it's
really based on obviously the
demographics of the area
you know i started this with fifteen
thousand dollars bootstrapped how did
you know to do franchisee
franchisor had you seen that model did
you see something so i didn't learn
i didn't know anything about it but when
i started this in my parents dining room
i said i'm going to franchise this
business why did you say that mcdonald's
because no because i i like orange
theory like not like what was on your
radar
i like the fact that you could bring a
lot of great smart minds together
and build a very powerful brand and i
want to create it i said as i said i
want to create a powerful movement
that i could bring everyone together
because if you know mcdonald's
the dollar menu the mcflurry those are
all started by franchisees
i don't have all the answers just like
you don't and we can learn from each
other everyone can learn from each other
but when you're allowed to surround
yourself with great people
you could build things at a faster speed
you thought that was smart i thought it
was genius
yep the model of franchisee is
franchisor absolutely yeah it's an
american there's a lot of headaches
though you know
i listen to you of course
everyone thinks it's so cool listen lay
down on the road let a car drive you
over
go in reverse drive you over then you'll
get a break for like three four weeks
lay down again it's gonna go over you
again and back what was the hardest
moment so how long when did you start
this
i started this in 2008. on some real
[ __ ] because i want to bring real bad
payroll for for almost 10 years every
single
two weeks i had to figure out how to
make payroll i think you told me over
lunch a scary one where you were like
really gee i was in a casino
right right yes you told me i drove to a
casino
donut do not do this do not do this i
didn't do it but don't don't listen to
me with them and i tell you an hour
so i'm in a casino i had my life savings
only had five grand left
and i was like all right i need 20 grand
if i could hit red red's obviously our
color you know
i was like if i could hit red then i'll
have 10.
i'm gonna double it and i can make
payroll so what happened again somebody
called you called somebody told me
um someone who's very successful he's
like been a mentor i was like
so you think this is a good idea he's
like hey
i'm in atlantic city i need to make
payroll it's twenty thousand i have five
thousand i'm gonna put on red red do you
think it's a good idea yeah it's like
josh it is this stupid
stupidest [ __ ] i've ever met he's like
but you got the biggest set i've ever
seen in my life you're crazy
doing that so oh he loved it loved it
and this guy self made
very successful so he loved it so i said
you know what it's a stupid idea so i
went back to my office
now this is what i can't say and you
called everybody right i remember today
every single day
i'm proud of myself right now thank you
so i called every single client
and a company yeah and i gave away over
hundreds of free sessions and raised 46
grand overnight
now i couldn't take credit cards because
i needed the money in the bank so i
literally would
i drove to everyone's house to collect
checks if if you're listening to this
and you complain and you're hanging out
at home on the weekend
that's a problem this is why people
don't get to the next level this is that
six dollar coffee thing that i had to
create clarity about the other day i
don't mind six dollar coffees i don't
mind 70 000
pairs of sneakers i i get mad when
people complain
and do things that make no sense 100 to
me this is just about complaining
you can go buy a boat a rolex or
whatever that means you have
a peep of complaining the second you go
into complaining mode i'm auditing the
[ __ ] out of you
gee do you know how many dm's i get a
day and i don't have a lot i'm still
like in the early stages
yeah like three four or five but anyway
i get the amazon and then oh you want to
grow your following no
no no oh no no and people like why don't
you want to grow your following you
should have millions of followers
because it takes time half the stuff out
there's fake
i have probably 90 gee i heard there's a
business now that you could rent a
private jet
a car and a whole set up for an hour to
do a shoot to pretend like you own it
people have been doing that left people
have been jumping fences
to take photos that they're going on
private plane at scale
crazy it's crazy we also live in a world
where 22 year olds are having plastic
surgery i know it's
i know it's crazy all that people want
to do is make pretend listen they're
successful
you're going to love this great content
you notice
you can compare that to entrepreneurship
any day of the week because you always
get to live to see another day
but in some situations i mean you know
like you'll die
but you could start at a certain point
because you got to a certain point and
you can continue
without having like three point one even
though you almost got to the end they go
exactly
but you know sometimes you could take 10
steps back to move 24 and sometimes take
five steps back
to move 10 forward i'm more like up up
down down left right left right baba
select start because that's unlimited
lives
i love it listen i love it that's how my
entrepreneurship works
look man contra [ __ ]
look you know it's funny you know you
and i agree with so many different
things like school for example
you know i look back to school look like
i was a horrible student
horrible didn't excite me didn't love it
and people go to college they waste all
their money
i think people should literally be
working for people who've done it how
old do i apologize for interrupting
now and so that means you started when
you were 25 25.
talk to me about 20 to 25. oh man were
you a knucklehead
no i was just depressed man you were
yeah tell me why
i don't know what i want to do in my
life you know people were like driving
around
see i you know i had a rough life
growing up rough and
and listen where'd you grow up i grew up
in new high park on long island
rough life you know and um but i don't
you can't make excuses
no i understand whatever cards you're
dealt deal with
listen people win 3-7 off suit all the
time that's it you just deal with them
you deal with them and honestly i
wouldn't change a thing in my life
because what resentment did you have
built up at that point did you want to
be rich
no i listen if you chase the money you
got a problem agreed you cannot chase
the money i'll tell you that right now
so many people have a twist in the wrong
i've always wanted i look i love fitness
i've always loved really loved it
the problem is doctors and trainers are
exactly the same a doctor without
patients unemployed
trainer without clients unemployed and i
said always say how can i make money
when i'm not working because
you got to work on your business not in
your business
i need to get paid so you were a trainer
i was a trainer i see and people used to
always laugh at me and i look at you
josh you're working at the gym you're a
trainer making ten dollars an hour
and did you like it no i just i loved it
when they made fun of you no i didn't
care because i just said you just wait
didn't hear
no i don't i tune that stuff listen i
got a problem it's on my neck
i look this way only i never turn back
this way you make a mistake
that's it someone's gonna sue you this
is the things that happen in business
people are gonna sue you people gonna
lie to you what are you most excited
about like right when you like now dream
yeah right you've got this thing rolling
a little bit like oh it's rolling
yeah what do you really how do you think
about the what is you know it's funny
when you said
europe it was funny when you said you're
obsessed with the jets it's really funny
i'm obsessed with chasing the jets yeah
like it's crazy how much i like process
over
degree let me give an example you know a
lot about me right you like you paid
attention
you know anything about this i mean it
like real talk you know anything about
it
that i do not know that is the single
biggest exit in the history of my life
wow that's a company called rezzy rosie
that years ago i started with ben
leventhal
then we brought over mike montero it was
incubated at vayner media
it was part of the vayner rsc fund that
i had we started it because i didn't
want to just invest
i wanted to build um and uh
and ben and mike did an incredible job i
was on the board uh there was a time
when the company was struggling i put
personal money into it
real check for me at the time um and
it exited to amex uh in the la within
the last year maybe nine months ago
maybe a year ago
for hefty nine figures that's great it
is the single biggest win on my record
it's great
nobody knows anything about it i'm
trying to remember why i said this oh
i like the process not the winning
moment i hear you man it's like
it's like funny you say that because you
know like i was telling some people you
know i'm going with gary today and
they're like oh my god that's amazing
that's great
he's so handsome you know
but um i i didn't look at it like that
like i really like truly believe you and
i are gonna have a good connection past
this and i got some big things like that
we'll talk off off record
but i just i was just excited to just
come here and just provide value and
just
look i've always been about when i get a
call from a woman
who's 414 pounds that couldn't have a
bariatric surgery that was drinking 17
slurpies a day and all she wanted to do
is have a family and have children
good for her and i personally changed
her life yes and she's 160 pounds and
she literally wants to get my name
tattooed on her
she calls me once a month like i get
emotional sometimes it's crazy
or like when someone's mom calls you up
because their kids being picked on
because they have no confidence and you
help them
like that legacy yeah that moves me and
i want to i want to continue to do that
because look in
in the fitness world people are
procrastinators
people can't turn on a machine they
can't open a nap dude it's so
unbelievable
back to you mean eliminating friction
yeah listen
it's the half pregnant version your
model is i understand super well
because i think god can afford having a
babysitter like the fact that in two
hours mike vicanti
is coming here by the way i learned
something about myself i'm getting much
better workouts in
in the evening than i am in the morning
that's right so i've like changed that
up a little bit but like
i needed a babysitter you need
accountability yeah
everyone needs accountability and you'll
never believe this everybody who's
listening
that's such a good point by josh let me
tell you about my accountability
i am not accountable to myself
i'm accountable to others it's why i'm
such a good leader yeah i think more
about jason and dust like i feel like
like i feel like i work for them for
real and once i figure that out with
work
work out i'm like wait a minute if i get
a full-time trader who babysits me
i don't want to let that literally i'm
doing well because i don't want to let
mike down
it's in the one moment in the last six
years that i had a little bit of a flop
which was the back half of last year
it's because jordan my trainer kind of
looks like you by the way
jordan my trainer at the time was burnt
out he was three years
he crushed i mean by the way between
soft tissue work and like
in a lot of ways brought me i don't want
to say more
mike and jordan have transformed my life
as going back and forth as my trainers
but what i asked them to do was
impossible which is [ __ ] your life
it's 100 my life you travel my schedule
when i want right
and he wore down and as soon as he wore
down and started like
like kind of like i'm not gonna travel
with you on this trip which led to
not coming like i'm sick like we both
worn down and i
lost i mean five and a half years
crushed i can't wait to look back at the
content
of mine from november december of last
year because i know
i'm like 15 pounds head like i'm already
down 12 pet like
i just need a babysitter because i'm a
cow because jordan
lost his way i wasn't accountable to him
anymore which
i lost if you're trying for me i'm
accountable for you and that's what i
needed
and it's and i think for a lot of people
listening right now i think the biggest
reason that you're not
eating well or working out is you're
like me you can't you're not competitive
with yourself
i've never wanted to be myself in
anything people like oh today i'm
i'm going to run it faster today i'm
like be yourself [ __ ] that i want to
beat somebody else i want to be
accountable to somebody else
once i figured that out it changed my
life with fitness
i think that's i'm just saying that
because i hope for one person they
figure out oh wait a minute i can't
afford a trainer that travels with me
like gary
but i'm gonna buddy up with somebody i'm
gonna be accountable to them and they're
gonna be accountable to me
i think i couldn't agree with you more
that's a really great insight yeah and
you you said something that was golden
you said that you work for them you know
i say that all the time
people don't understand that good
leaders always create other good leaders
it's very important to understand
and at the end of the day when you're
like thinking that you know someone else
is your employee like i hate that word
i'm not a fan of i don't know if you're
a fan of that word at all or not you
know what's so funny
i'm really funny with words i think
we're in a hyper sensitive america where
people analyze words i care about intent
to your point i understand where you're
going and i appreciate it for me
personally
i'll use any word i'm curious about
action action
yeah you know what i mean like i'm
thrilled to call dustin my employee but
like how i treat him
is like you know also i think i put
certain words on pedestals
that are not how they're to your point i
think you're we're saying the same thing
yeah and i think yeah emotional
intelligence i live by it it's the game
it
100 what do we need to touch on before
we get out of here cause it's all moved
so fast
what have we not talked about what do we
have not touched on
listen honestly i i i think it's been
pretty good you know i think it's been
pretty good you know i think
what do you what do you um actually you
didn't answer this question because i
probably cut you off because i'm good at
that
what what are you like what are you
excited about in like 10 or 15 or 20
like
what do you dream about now right like
what do you like what are you thinking
about like
let me ask some fun questions do you
think your company will go public
i'm not sure do you think you'll sell it
yes
so you think more likely a private
equity firm buys at a big scale what's
the minority minority
i understand so okay so you want to stop
i'm gonna listen i've turned down a lot
of money already
i believe you and my wife you're gonna
get to the apex moment that you feel in
your heart
take some money off the board so you can
feel that win my wife won't listen to
this so we're okay but i've never
shared with her if i share with her
she'll kill me but what i've turned down
because i believe
you got to believe if you don't believe
you're never going anywhere you have to
really believe
the amount of people that sold too early
is all time
it's crazy you got to believe everyone
wants instant there's no interesting
things i was on cnn the day instagram
sold to facebook for a billion dollars
500 days in the company and i said that
facebook stole it i got [ __ ] on
i'm historically correct you are there's
another success
now who knows if they would have been
able to scale that i think kevin was the
reason people sell out is because
they want it yeah but but the game is
also so hard that people just walk away
and they can't i was talking to a guy
the other day
he walked away because he said he
couldn't handle it anymore
i respect that yeah there's nothing
wrong with that there really isn't like
i'm gonna throw you for a real curveball
i will have no judgment against myself
if i wake up one morning and say you
know what i don't want to do this
i want to like i'm thinking about
selling everything and just becoming a
sports card dealer again
because i'm really hot on it for a
couple years
no but i really think to your point we
enjoy it
yeah like to me the second i don't like
it is the second i'll be a dnf student
part you know what is part of me look i
love
being against the wall part of me loves
it i don't know you know what's
interesting that i'm curious if it's
gonna happen to you
i think the reason i've jumped around
and done a lot of [ __ ] is i'm only most
comfortable when i'm an underdog
i love it i don't like i actually hate
what's going on with garyvee
you know it's i'm a little bit scared of
it i'm like [ __ ] i'm gonna start getting
overrated you know with all the things
that are happening i feel like
if i get into a place where i'm like i'm
starting a coffee brand and everyone
collectively or the majority is like oh
this is gonna crush
i'm gonna be in trouble i have to like
that's why the sports car thing is so
fun for me like i know my inner circle
and i know my community
people [ __ ] on me quietly because now
it's a little scarier to [ __ ] on me
publicly
because i've been right enough but like
people are like no way
and like that's why i like it so much
yeah i still got my hockey card
collection by the way if you ever
hockey's
yeah no i get it it's just not enough
demand supplies
um okay do
you want to be a famous entrepreneur
well i think that kind of comes with the
territory i should keep growing you know
there's people way bigger than me
and cuban and damon john and everybody
that
nobody knows who the [ __ ] they are do
you like
kind of the the limelight of like a
winning entrepreneur you like that
to some degree to some degree does it
scare you to admit more
to the degree because i think a lot
about this right like is it douchey
is it narcissistic like i'm empathetic
it's an interesting question here's what
i think i i like i
i never include my family in anything
like social media i'm not that guy
i worry about that like sometimes i
think about with you like like when
you're out with your family
and people are coming up to you you know
what's funny by not sharing it people
understand the rules a little bit
yeah the fact that i never share my life
my personal life
a lot people are going to always say
what's up but like there's definitely
like it's crazy if i'm solo
it's like i'm into like in the right
moments it's beetle me like it's
i can't believe how many people who know
the [ __ ] i am but
when i'm doing personal stuff and my
kids like things of that nature
like people do it different they'll give
you the wink like whereas they'll take
the selfie if i'm solo
and come and like pitch me their idea or
ask me a question or take a selfie when
i'm with them
it's more of like that respect like wink
wink because they know like [ __ ]
i've never seen his kids you know true i
like that it's kind of cool like some
people don't
back to like who's going to jail some
people don't have emotional intelligence
and they steamroll and then i'm i'm not
pissed i'm actually empathetic
but i'm definitely not open to it it's
like the tire tyler showed me the tire
at the wrong second
if you're gonna roll up on me and pitch
your business without even asking when
i'm holding my two kids hands
there's a 100 chance that i [ __ ] hate
you yeah i agree like you know like like
like
you know but if you like kind of like
hey do you have a second i know you're
with your family
already 100 love of you i'll still
probably say no
it just it's like tacked it's like tack
i still don't even you know it's so
funny i don't even actually hate you 100
because i'm still so [ __ ] flattered
that anybody would want to ask me that i
can never get away from that feeling
but it's kind of like hey you know the
score like be kind
but i get it because you get excited and
you think this is your only shot i get
it i understand it it
still doesn't make me feel like i my
kids get upset
yeah i'm sure they don't get enough time
with me so then like somebody pitching
me is not like how they want to spend
that saturday afternoon
so that breaks my heart you know it's
just a whole [ __ ] thing yeah i'll
tell you something else
look my gym guys franchise family
members is the number one
who i serve and the ability that i could
bring people into my system
just like i changed what's her name's
life donna and everyone else and i could
help people run a successful business
model
that's the best especially when like
that to me is and
and it's the best because it's it's
selfless and selfish
if you're doing that for dustin as a
franchisee it's the best feeling
and you're winning too and that's okay i
keep telling my friends i'm like
i love making people happy and feeling
good i also want to [ __ ] build an
empire
you can do both right now we're in this
world where you can't do both it's crazy
build an empire i want to build an
empire in the nicest way of all time
because the world's abundant your empire
and his empire and his empire
and her empire are not at the expense of
my umpire like if you're good enough
you're gonna
you can't stop winners can can't stop
them
can't no way if you're a winner you're
gonna keep winning that's it what's your
uh instagram handle
it's joshua gigi josh york ggg what's
the gg
jim guys i know i'm on man i'm trying to
say that was stocked into malone i know
what the [ __ ]
would you be branding you need to oh if
you're if you're not look
i literally went to a conference
recently everyone in the whole room they
all have businesses
i'm the only one branding i was actually
speaking yeah i was the only one
branding
why are you not branding if you that's a
per that's an opportunity to talk about
your company
and get out to somebody else you gotta
always be out there renting very
important
if you believe in what you you're
selling it's there's nothing better
that's it
thanks for being on brother thank you
for having me